Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus Karfreitag Richard
Osterausgabe so schön ich liebe Ostern
weißt du warum weil weil es oben auf dem
Berg wieder so nach Sommer riecht dann
kommt so diese warme erste Frühlingsluft
weißt du die kommt so langsam aus dem
Tal nach oben gekrochen und du weißt es
ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten es ist egal
was passiert dann graupelst dazwischen
und dann schneit's wieder und dann Wind
jetzt wieder und so aber es ist nicht
mehr aufzuhalten und deswegen liebe ich
Ostern weil es dieses Frühlingsgefühl
ist so so Aufbruch Auferstehung und
damit sind wir auch schon beim beim
Thema Richard also erstmal wenn es um
Natur geht höre ich dich doch immer
dichten also das war von Hermann Löns
was du da gemacht hast ja das stimmt da
will ich immer so ein bisschen lyrisch
ja ich bin so ein Romantiker
aber du bist doch eigentlich auch ein
heimlicher Romantiker oder
ja ich weiß gar nicht ob ein heimlicher
Romantiker ein Romantiker ist also ich
meine du bist heimlich an Romantiker du
wirkst ja immer so wahnsinnig so
wahnsinnig intellektuell jemand der die
Argumente kennt der dem so Gefühle
verdächtig sind weißt du es braucht man
nicht okay also meine meine eigene
Gefühle waren wir noch nie für dich
aber ich ich bin das habe ich aber erst
im Laufe meines Lebens so gemerkt
eigentlich bin ich Romantiker ohne dass
sie mich jemals so wirklich dazu bekannt
habe ich kann mich bis heute wenn so der
Vollmond ja egal wo ich gerade bin wenn
der so so über den Horizont sich schieb
plötzlich diese Riesen Kugel
wirklich ah da könnte ich sterben ist
einfach so schön ergeben weil es jetzt
vorbei wäre es okay okay also ich
empfehle dir die Romane von Arno Schmidt
zu lesen ja da gibt es mehr Mond
Metaphern als in der gesamten Welt
Literatur zusammen
die sind nicht immer so romantisch aber
die sind schön also ich erinnere mich
das heißt wenn der Mond mir wie eine
Aspirin Tablette vorkommt liegt an mir
oder liegt es an Bayer Leverkusen
das ist so die Art von Romantik die mir
gefällt ja sehr schön Richard Ostern
bist du gläubiger Mensch habe ich mich
gefragt auf der Party hier was glaubst
Du
doch man glaubt ja viel so den ganzen
hinten langen Tag ja aber ich meine du
du meinst ob ich einen neuen Leben nach
dem Tod glaube zum Beispiel ja zum
Beispiel und wenn ja wie stellst du dir
das vor und ist das schön so etwas zu
haben oder nicht ich finde das schön mir
das nicht vorzustellen das ist die
ehrliche Antwort darauf also es gibt ja
diesen
witzigen zwei Fragen und der eine ist
gibt es ein Leben nach dem Tod und
werden sie dort in der Lage sein 100 $
scheint so wechseln und das sagt ja
ziemlich klar aus wie konkret soll man
sich das denn vorstellen
und
ich bin eigentlich so so ein bisschen
eher dass nicht mehr denke so so schön
wie das Leben kann eine Ewigkeit
eigentlich nicht sein also so leidvoll
Leben auch ist aber alle schönen Dinge
im Leben entstehen ja durch den Kontrast
also wenn es keinen leiden gäbe dann geb
ich eben auch keine Freude das gehört
dem Leben untrennbar zusammen und diese
Vorstellung eines ewigen Paradieses in
dem alles gut ist die ist ja für den
menschlichen Geist nicht positiv
vorstellbar stellt man sich ja unendlich
langweilig vor wenn man anfängt die
eigene Fantasie ernst zu nehmen jetzt
muss ich mir also auch noch vorstellen
dass dieser Mechanismus dass man nur
Freude empfinden kann wenn es leiden
gibt und dass die Dinge nur dann schön
sind wenn sie auch hässlich sein könnten
dass der ja gebrochen sein muss in
diesem riesigen leben ja also man darf
nicht mehr so empfinden wie hier auf
Erden
und wenn ich mir das so überlege es gab
jemand der der das mal versucht hat in
Ruhe durchzudenken und das war das womit
ich mich persönlich religiös am meisten
beschäftigt habe und das war Immanuel
swedenburg okay ich habe ja mal mit
meinem Bruder zusammen Roman geschrieben
er spielt emmanuels Wiedenbrück eine
große Rolle und er war auch Inspirator
für viele bedeutende Philosophen wie zum
Beispiel für Shelly es werden Bock war
eine
schwedischer
allroundwissenschaftler ein universal
Gelehrter der zu seinen Zeiten sehr
berühmt war im 18 Jahrhundert und der
bis 50 Jahren alles mögliche gemacht
hatte ja also ein Buch über die
schwedische Währung geschrieben er war
direkt oder im Bergbau was der
wichtigste Industriezweig in Schweden
waren
er hatte sich mit Psychologie
beschäftigt der war nach England
gefahren und hatte bei Flames diet neben
Newton und Hailey dem bedeutendsten
englischen Astronomen in der Werkstatt
gestanden und
zugeguckt wie der seine Instrumente
gebaut hat und sein himmelsack
geschrieben also es war ein richtiger
Allround Gelehrter der damaligen Zeit
und so im Alter von 50 kriegt er auf
einmal religiöse Visionen
und das fand der seltsamen hatte auch
ausführlich protokolliert und das kam
mir im eigenartig vor und der fing also
an sich selbst aufzuschreiben und zu
beobachten was ist los mit mir spinne
ich oder passiert hier irgendwas
übernatürliches
und irgendwann hat er sich dafür
entschieden dass er nicht schwimmt und
dann hat er ein wahnsinnig umfangreiches
Werk darüber geschrieben wie es im
Himmel und wie es in der Hölle aussieht
cool und zwar wahnsinnig umfangreich
also lauter quarkbänder also so große
dicke schwere Bücher ja und was er auf
seinen Reisen sein Visionen und
auditionen alles so im Jenseits erlebt
hat und das Schöne weißwildenburg ist
dass die Frage ob man in den Himmel
kommt oder in die Hölle das darf man
sich aus
optional ja und das finde ich cool das
finde ich schon mal ziemlich gut aber
man weiß ja nicht wo man sich wo man
sich wohler fühlt ja weil er sagt weil
er sagt für einen schlechten Menschen ja
ist der Himmel die Hölle ja das ist da
fühlt er sich überhaupt nicht wohl unter
Seinesgleichen
sind dann sozusagen die ganzen die sich
fürs schlechte entschieden haben unter
sich super ne und die können dann ihre
Intrigen spinnen und sich übers Ohr
hauen das was ich was und so und sind
auf ihre Art und Weise in der Hölle
sollte man das wollen wollen wenn dein
Nachbar Sadam Hussein ist naja der
Himmel als Alternative bedeutet
eigentlich studieren bei schwedenburg
okay also da gibt es Akademien wo man
lebenslang studiert im Grunde genommen
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass viele
Leute wenn sie die Alternative hätten
zwischen dieser Hölle diesem Spiel
Casino und dieser himmlischen Akademie
sich für die Hölle entscheiden ja
definitiv also ich bin dabei also er hat
die willens Freiheit des Menschen ne
damals ein wichtiges Thema
Aufklärungszeit so ernst genommen dass
er sie auch auf in die
Transzendenz mit rüber genommen hat und
gesagt du bist immer frei auch wenn du
gestorben bist die auszusuchen wo Du hin
das ist ja spannend natürlich was ist
das für eine Vorstellung also oder
anders gefragt du hast dich ja viel mit
dem Thema beschäftigt diese diese Idee
das sozusagen Körper und Seele etwas
unterschiedliches sind
und dass ein Körper irgendwann einfach
zurückkehrt zu dem was er vorher war
wesentlichen Kohlenstoff und du wirst
einfach verstoffwechselt und wirst quasi
wieder Erde und das die Natur hat ihren
großen Kreis gedreht aber dann getrennt
davon die Seele die dann aufsteigt ins
Paradies und so weiter und ich habe
einen so großartigen Satz von dir
gefunden zu dem Thema der da lautet
nichts mehr Paradies und aufsteigen
sondern nach deiner Vorstellung hängt
die Seele im Hades wie eine
verschrumpelte Fledermaus ja
das ist das bezieht sich auf den
altgriechischen glauben
also wenn man jetzt die ganze Geschichte
mal warum glauben wir das was wir heute
glauben christliche Prägung und so wenn
man dann die mal zurückgehen immer
weiter immer weiter zurück und mal so
gucken was in unserer ältesten
Kulturzeugnisse der abendländischen
Kultur ne die ältesten Schriften das
sind die von hesiot und von Homer zum
Beispiel so und wenn man sich da die
eine Vorstellung macht was ist der mit
der Seele was ist denn mit Achilles
stirbt ja oder Hektor wo kommt denn
deren Seele hin dann gab es wirklich
diese Vorstellung dass die Seele in den
Hades kommt genau diese Unterhalt ne in
der da kommt sie hin und da macht sie ja
nichts mehr ne also die die hängt da
irgendwo rum und ist sozusagen völlig
Erlebnis aller und weil Unterwelt und
deswegen mein Vergleiche verschrumpelte
Fledermaus hängt da irgendwie von der
Decke ja und und macht sonst diesen
Fährmann ich erinnere mich ein Stück den
Fluss aber den Fährmann gab es doch auch
haben immer mit seinem Lachen
genau okay ja und das war also jetzt ja
keine schöne Vorstellung für
was dann in der Unterwelt passiert so
und dann entsteht irgendwann eine andere
Geschichte du kennst doch diese
Geschichte von Orpheus in der Unterwelt
genau der da Eurydike wieder rausholen
will ja seine Geliebte und der steigt
dann darunter und erholt sie ja
irgendwie wieder raus und damit beginnt
so in Thessalien im nördlichen
Griechenland ein aus dieser Orpheus den
ist ja historisch nicht gegeben hat aber
der wird sozusagen seine literarischen
Figur und nach dieser literarischen
Figur bildet sich eine
Religionsgemeinschaft die sich über das
ganz alte Griechenland
immer immer weiter ausbreitet und die
glauben an die Wiedergeburt okay und das
ist deswegen so interessant weil das
zeitlich ungefähr parallel läuft zur
Entstehung des wiedergeburts Gedankens
im Buddhismus und dem Hinduismus das
heißt ungefähr die selbe Zeit wir reden
jetzt so 6 bis 70 jahrhundert vor
Christus okay also lange vor christliche
lange vor Christi Geburt und im
Mittelmeerraum also vor allen Dingen in
den südlichen Gebieten hier Sizilien und
sie er sieht Italien manchen Stellen
Griechenlands da können wir ziemlich
sicher sein dass die Menschen an die
Wiedergeburten geglaubt haben das ist
also uralter mediterraner glaube
das war schöner als die Fledermaus
Vorstellung war eben diese Orpheus
Gedanke ja man steigt wieder aus ja und
diese Wiedergeburt dieser Gedanke zum
Beispiel der ja gerade sehr hübsch ist
ja diese Idee wiedergeboren zu werden
der hat dich nie fasziniert der hat dich
nie gekriegt naja also wenn man sich mit
der Wiedergeburt ausführlich beschäftigt
ich habe das natürlich etwas mehr so im
mediterranen Kultur neues gemacht ich
kann dich nicht so gut aus mit den
ostasiatischen wiedergeburtsfantasien
das ist ja da wird ja die Wiedergeburt
relativ schnell negativ bewertet ja
nämlich das ist so ein Fluch ist dass
man immer wieder geboren um
wiedergeboren wird solange man keine
Reinheit und Vollkommenheit erreicht ich
glaube das ist so ein Buddhismus ein
bisschen ähnlich ja genau und das heißt
also es ist die ewige Wiederkehr des
sinnlosen gleich du fängst immer wieder
von vorne an und immer wieder in dem
Versuch was Besseres zu werden und wenn
du den verpfuscht dann wirst du was
schlechteres und deine Ausgangssituation
die wird natürlich immer elender ja also
wenn du als Fledermaus geboren wirst es
ist einfach schwerer ein ethisch
perfektes Leben zu leben um sich für
eine bessere Tiergestalt zu
qualifizieren und wenn du irgendwann auf
die Ebene eines Steins abgesunken bist
hast du auf ewig verloren
oder Milliarden bist Du wiedergeboren
wirst aber du hast auch keine Chance
mehr daraus zu kommen die Hölle also
irgendwie so richtig durchdacht erschien
mir das ja so ein upgrading als Bambi
wiederzukommen ist schwierig das heißt
es ist so richtig darum verbessert dich
mal verbessert dich
vom Stein ja zum zum Hasen und von dort
aus zum Menschen und ist ja schon
schwierig genug als Mensch ein Weiser zu
werden ja der irgendwie das ewige Leben
dann verdient hat und das ewige Leben
besteht ja dann in der Befreiung aus dem
menschlichen Körper ja also am Ende ist
der ganze Sinn der wirgeburt dass das
mal ein Ende hat ja so dass mich wundere
wenn Leute sagen das ist eine tröstliche
Vorstellung ich meine ich kann mir
vorstellen es gibt Leute die würden
gerne irgendwie als Hund wiedergeboren
und so weiter aber ich stehe mir ein
Leben als Hund ja als Adler finde ich ja
schon gut also wenn dann irgendwann habe
ich dann
als greift als Philippinen aber
Ostern sprechen
Ostern die die Frage
wer war diese historische Figur Jesus
von Nazareth was ist da eigentlich
passiert
könnte es sein oder wie konnte es
passieren dass die sehr Religion anders
wie konnte es sein dass ein
Wanderprediger aus Galiläa dass der
plötzlich zu einem Religionsstifter wird
was war deiner Meinung nach der Auslöser
dafür
was ist da gesichert passiert gibt es
überhaupt etwas was gesichert passiert
ist und was war sozusagen der Urknall
für das Christentum was willst du sagen
also wir sind jetzt ganz viele Fragen
offen in der absoluten kurz
Zusammenfassung
jesus ist nicht sicher historisch
verbrieft
man kann aber sein die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass er gelebt hat
ist sicher höher als dass er nicht
gelebt hat und das einzige richtige
Quellen Dokument was wir haben das ist
90 Jahre nach Christi Geburt also 60
Jahre nach dem mutmaßlichen Tod von
Jesus verfasst worden und das sind die
jüdischen Altertümer von Flavius
Josephus jüdischer
geschichtsschreiberistische jüdischer
Geschichtsschreiber der mehrere Bücher
geschrieben hat über die damaligen
Ereignisse seinerzeit und in der Zeit
davor
und da hat er drei vier Sätze
geschrieben über Jesus
und da beschreibt er Jesus als ein
weisen Menschen
an dem viele gefolgt sind und der von
Pontius Pilatus zum Kreuz ist tot
verurteilt wurde und das ist eine
Religionsgemeinschaft namens Christen
gibt die im nachfolgen
diese Sätze hat ja so oder ähnlich
wahrscheinlich wirklich geschrieben und
dann haben und das vermutet man mit
hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit die Christen
nachher in diesen Text noch ein paar
andere Sätze mit reingeschrieben zum
Beispiel er war der Christus
also
quasi der der Messias der Erlöser der
von Gott gesandte der Gesalbte das hat
Flavius Josephus mit Sicherheit nicht
geschrieben weil er kein Christ war er
glaubte das nicht dass Jesus der
Christus ist er hat die einfach nur
Notiz von ihm genommen und hat ihn da
erwähnt
was wir zu vermuten können wenn wir
sagen ja was könnte denn sowas ist denn
Konsens wenn man sich anguckt versteht
in den vier Evangelien was kann man da
als historische Weisheit rausfiltern
dann kann man sagen wir keine
Geschichtsbücher sind ne und auch nicht
gedacht waren nein Bekenntnis Literatur
ist was ganz anderes das sind
Glaubensbekenntnisse ich meine wir leben
in einer Zeit in der man sich unter
Geschichtsschreibung sowieso nicht
dasselbe vorgestellt hat klar es gab
schon römische und griechische
Historiker aber auch bei denen ist
vieles abenteuerlich es ist nun mal
lustig sich anzugucken wie die Zahlen
damals benutzt worden sind also wenn
wenn Hero dort eine Perserkriegen
schreibt und die Größe der persischen
Armee beschreibt dann hat später mein
Militärhistoriker ausgerechnet als die
Armee das gesagt ist wenn die in
Persepolis losgegangen wäre und die
wären im preußischer Schlachtordnung
marschiert dann werden die letzten noch
nicht aus persipulus raus gewesen wenn
die ersten schon in Griechenland gewesen
also völlig absurde Zahl ja
unübersichtlich ja also klar war wusste
nicht das was sie heute ist ja und jeder
der Geschichte schreibt hat auch
meistens in Interesse und in der
damaligen Zeit war das genauso also die
einen besonders heldenhaft und die
anderen besonders böse dann so schnell
und so naja jedenfalls die Evangelien
hatten keine Funktion als historische
Quellen wahrgenommen zu werden aber wir
gehen mal davon aus dass dieser Jesus
von Nazareth einer von hunderten ja wenn
ich sogar noch mehr Wanderprediger war
von denen es im Israel der damaligen
Zeit also der römischen Provinz Judäa
ganz ganz viele gab und zwar aber dass
er fromme Menschen waren und B weil sie
von den Römern besetzt waren und alle
eben auf den Messias warteten den großen
Feldherrn der sie von den Römern erlöst
und das war untrennbar mit Religionen
verbunden man erwartet also sozusagen
den den von Gott gesandten Krieger der
die Römer besiegt
und
ob Jesus sich selbst so gesehen hat am
Anfang seines Wirkens ist nicht ganz
klar er ist in einem relativ
überschaubaren Gebiet rumgezogen diese
schönen Worte kaperna um und genau sehen
sie genezarettes und was wäre da alles
so in Ordnung haben das ist so ein
Gebiet so groß wie es Bergische Land da
ist ja ein Jahr rumgezogen einige sind
nachgefolgt und dann hat er sich auf die
Socken gemacht über 200 km bis nach
Jerusalem um da beim pässerfest Aufzug
schlagen und das ist so das Passahfest
war ja das große lösungsfest feiert man
den Auszug aus Ägypten höchstens der der
Juden und da kamen natürlich immer ganz
ganz viele Wanderprediger von überall
hin in die Stadt ne weil das war ja
sozusagen der der absolute religiöse Tag
und für die Römer super gefährlich
Aufruhr Aufruhr Unruhen und so weiter
also nehmen wir an dass der römische
Präfekt Pontius Pilatus über dem wir
fast gar nichts wissen ja annehmen dass
der Name möglicherweise stimmt vielmehr
kann man gar nicht sagen es gibt eine
Erwähnung später dass er mal ganz
blutigen Aufstand hat niederschlagen
lassen also wenn man irgendetwas über
ihn vermutet dann ist das dass es eine
ziemlich skrupellose type gewesen ist
der auch bestechlich und korrupt gewesen
sein soll ist auch klar warum er das war
wer wollte dahin also unter all den
römischen Provinzen war das wirklich die
war nicht reich die war arm und die war
voller religiöser Fanatiker richtig ja
das war so ein Schleudersitz und wenn
man da jemand hinschickte dann schickte
man jemanden fürs Grobe dahin
und dieser Pontius Pilatus hat ihn dann
so wie Josephus Flavius Josephus
schreibt ans Kreuz schlagen lassen weil
er im Tempel randaliert hat und ich habe
das hier schon mal erzählt der große
Widerspruch besteht darin dass dieser
Jesus der ein Weltuntergangs Prediger
war der also seinen Leuten gesagt hat
wenn er mir nachfolgt dann werdet ihr
überleben weil die Welt geht unter
das der
gleichzeitig ja diese sozial Ethik
vertreten hat der Bergpredigt ja und
wenn jemand hier auf die eine Backe
schlägt halt eben auch die andere hin
und so weiter also diese diese
Gewaltfreiheit und das Verzeihen in den
Mittelpunkt seiner Religion stellt dass
der
da im Tempel randaliert und die Stellage
eine Händler umschmeißt das ist eine
ganz merkwürdige Geschichte die passt
hinten und vorne nicht zusammen weil
diese Händler waren damit Absicht die
waren auch nicht böse nee die waren da
um Opfertiere zu verkaufen Tiere zu
verkaufen ja ja man stellt sich immer
vor jeder hätte seine opf ihre
mitgebracht nach Jerusalem also zum
besserfest kommen die Leute von überall
her in die Stadt ja und dann ist es
natürlich viel besser du kaufst dir das
Opferlamm ja direkt im Tempelhof als
dass du das jetzt 200 Kilometer mit dir
rumschleppen musst das ist auch völlig
logisch dass das so ist und dass er da
so außer sich geraten sein soll und dass
er da also die die Stellagen auf den die
Opfertiere waren ungeschmissen haben
soll das ist eigenartig das passt nicht
so richtig
und jedenfalls für diesen Akt des
randalierens wird er wegen des Aufruhrs
dann von der römischen Obrigkeit
verurteilt verurteilt wurde
gesichert ne das weiß ich jetzt so
erzählt habe ist sowas was man so als
Möglichkeit so daraus filtern kann
die Frage ist ja trotzdem Richard also
mich ich gebe es ganz ehrlich zu ich war
auch in den letzten Jahren viel dort in
dieser Gegend unterwegs und mit und dann
da mal stehst zum See Genezareth zum
Beispiel oder auch in Kapern am oder
Kapern haben oder wie auch immer wirst
nennen wollen anderen Ort den
bethlehemmen wenn du in dieser
Geburtskirche stehst und so weiter mich
berührt hast das lässt einen nicht kalt
und die große Frage die mich immer
beschäftigt ist
wann wurde aus diesem Reformer aus
diesem Wanderprediger aus diesem
weltuntergangsprediger Jesus von
Nazareth der Begründer einer neuen
Religion ich meine wenn man sich das mal
vorstellt sehr glaube ich relativ
gesichert der wird 30 oder 33 Jahre alt
mutmaßlich
und in den ersten 30 Jahren hörst du von
diesem Menschen nichts richtig und dann
kommen die letzten drei Jahre und das
eigentlich ist es ein Jahr es ist ein
genau genau und eigentlich ist es sogar
nur eine Woche eigentlich ist es sind es
wenige Tage nämlich diese Ereignisse die
du gerade ansprichst Ostern Jerusalem
die dann die entscheidende Rolle spielen
und jetzt habe ich mich mit etwas
beschäftigt worüber ich mit dir mal
reden wollte Richard also das ganze
Personal umsetzen sozusagen über das
widersprechen ist ja alles jüdisch ja
alles jüdisch ja ja bist aber Pilatus
den Römer bis auf Pilatus den Römer so
in in meiner Kindheit ja in in den
Südtiroler Bergen ja wir waren sehr
häufig in der Kirche und ich kenne diese
Geschichte wirklich rauf und runter und
und habe das alles immer mitgemacht und
so weiter auch später im Internat und
fand es auch alles immer sehr
interessant die Bibel ist eine
großartige Erzählung speziell das Neue
Testament und das was du Bergpredigt
gerade angesprochen hast das ist
faszinierend bis heute und man würde es
jemandem wie Vladimir Putin mal wünschen
dass er sich das einfach mal zu Gemüte
führt und dann würde er vielleicht zu
anderen Entscheidungen kommen weil das
ist das ist eine schöne Vision für das
Zusammenleben von Menschen das ist nicht
mal so sagen eine gute
Bedienungsanleitung fürs Leben so was
dort nie aufgetaucht ist dass alle
handelnden Personen jüdisch sind sondern
das Gefühl war immer die Juden haben
Jesus umgebracht ja dass der größte
Quatsch schlechthin natürlich also
erstmal muss man ja sagen weil Jesus ja
selber ein Jude ja ich weiß ist der eine
zweite Christen ja keine nicht Juden so
das ist ein jüdischer Reformer das heißt
er wollte ja nicht eine neue Religion
Gründen sondern er wollte das Judentum
reformieren so es war sozusagen eine
Ausrede nicht jüdische Sekte so und wenn
du wenn du dir das anschaust was
auffällt ist und das ist so interessant
und darüber reden ja auch Historiker in
allen vier Evangelien über du gerade
auch gesprochen haben ja also von von
Lukas bis Johannes ja Markus und alles
was da ist in allen vier Evangelien wird
der Präfekt also wird Pontius Pilatus
von dem du gerade sagtest es ist eher
davon auszugehen dass das ein ziemlicher
Haudegen war ja und kein zart fühlender
Verwalter dieser Provinz der sagte oh da
ist jetzt einer der hat im Tempel
randaliert und so weiter aber ich glaube
trotzdem dass der unschuldig ist ja das
ist ja sehr unwahrscheinlich
und äußerst und trotzdem wird er als
milde und besonnen dargestellt ja er
hält Jesus für unschuldig und nur weil
der böse Mob also mit anderen
genau Druck macht fällt er schließlich
die des Todesurteil und das heißt dem
Klartext die Juden tragen die volle
Verantwortung für die Kreuzigung und die
frage mich ob sozusagen das ist auch
glaube ich der die historische Debatte
die es dann immer wieder gab ist wenn
man wenn man das sich hinschaut ist das
sozusagen der Kern dieses unsägliche
Antisemitismus der dann später in
Deutschland 33 bis 45 das gemacht hat
was er gemacht also der Kern ist es
sicher nicht aber es ist später
instrumentalisiert worden man hat sich
das dann so rausgefischt und es kam
einem sehr zu pass ich glaube es gibt
viele viele Wurzeln für den
Antisemitismus ich glaube nicht dass er
ursprünglich historisch daherkommt es
ging eigentlich um was anderes
dass der der wahre Begründer des
Christentums Paulus ja der der diese
Geschichte von diesem Wanderprediger
nimmt um daraus Christentum zu schmieden
der vielleicht der eigentliche
religionsbilder
Religionsstifter nennen Jesus Geschichte
geht ja eigentlich traurig zu Ende also
der Wanderprediger sagt folgt mir nach
das Reich Gottes kommt und so weiter er
geht also ins religiöse Zentrum in die
Hauptstadt nach Jerusalem und was
passiert die Welt geht nicht unter und
die Christen werden gerettet oder die
Nachfolger Jesu werden gerettet sondern
ähm was passiert was anderes die Römer
schlagen ihn als Kreuz jetzt könnte man
ja sagen es ist alles sagen oh scheiße
wir sind ein Irrtum aufgesessen war
alles ganz anders und so wäre das
normalerweise im Sande verlaufen
und das Interessante ist eben dass diese
diese
Anhängerschar ist geschafft hat diese
Geschichte in ihrem Kopf so rumzudrehen
dass daraus irgendwie eine
Erfolgsgeschichte wird und das ging nur
weil man behauptet hat dass das grableer
war er ist dann auferstanden genau ja
das Christentums wichtig ist auch er ist
der leiblich auferstanden richtig er ist
nicht seelisch auferstanden
im Grab das hätte man ja nicht beweisen
können ne aber abgesehen davon in der
alten orientalischen Vorstellung der
Levante Völker und das gilt also auch
für das Judentum bei jeder Auferstehung
genau über den Ägyptern ja wo wo das
Judentum ja ursprünglich mal
wahrscheinlich hier kommt
leibliche Auferstehung eine genauso wie
der fahrero einbalsamiert wird ja und
dass der ja auch im Totenreich leiblich
auferstehen und hier war es nicht die
gleiche Vorstellung dass Judentum
glaubte an die leibliche Auferstehung
und deswegen musste Jesus also den den
Emma aus Jüngern begegnen und musste das
grableer sein und so weiter und aus
dieser Geschichte des leeren Grabes das
war quasi überhaupt erst der Urknall
dass eine neue Religion entstehen konnte
weil viele Menschen das eben
offensichtlich geglaubt haben und dann
war die akrobatische Leistung von Paulus
diese ganze Jesusgeschichte stimmig zu
machen also eine Erklärung dafür zu
finden warum denn Jesus mit Absicht und
mit Gottes Willen gestorben sei
das war die Idee zu sagen war das nicht
damals so dass Adam im Paradies sind
erkenntnisapfel gegessen hat vom Baum
der Erkenntnis das war ja der Sündenfall
und diesen Sündenfall den hat Jesus
gesühnt durch seinen Tod am Kreuz das
ist ja nichts was Jesus selber gesagt
hätte sondern das in Erfindung von
Paulus und jetzt kriegt die Geschichte
auf einmal was rundes und was stimmiges
und dann wird missioniert und dann wird
er bis nach Griechenland gezogen und
nach Rom und man breitet sich aus in die
Gebiete der Perser und in der ganzen
Levante Region und schreibt dafür vier
Evangelien also Leute aus dem
pauluskreis oder eher selber niemand
weiß wer die waren alle ein bisschen
verschieden alle ein bisschen angepasst
an jeweilige Region in der man
missionieren will
wir haben zum Beispiel das
Johannesevangelium das für den
griechischen Sprachraum konzipiert
worden ist das anfängt mit dem Anfang
war der Logos
ja genau das ist schlecht über
eigentlich heißt es ja sowas wie der
Geist der von humpft ne das ist der
Anfang und das ist natürlich reiner
Platonismus also dass das Ganze Johannes
der Evangelium ist sozusagen durchdringt
von Platonismus und war damit
anschlussfähig an die bestehende
griechische Philosophie ich habe diesen
diesen Satz ne das ist einer der ganz
wenigen griechischen Sätze die mir
hängengeblieben sind er nachher in
hollogos ja am Anfang war das Wort das
ist ein so großartiger Anfang für eine
Erzählung ne finde ich ja dass Johannes
Evangelium ist sowieso sehr poetisch
sehr sehr ja wirklich ja ja absolut ist
richtig was ich halt interessant fand
war dieser dieser Punkt der viele
Historiker offensichtlich beschäftigt ne
also die Frage woher kommt weil du
gerade die Evangelien erwähnst diese
Süßholz raste sich sozusagen der diese
Schleimerei der Evangelisten an dem
Punkt warum gehen die mit diesem Pontius
Pilatus der mutmaßlich diesen
Wanderprediger ja zum Todesfall
mutmaßlich ja warum gehen die so so
Römer war und wenn ich nach oben gehe
man Mission
genau
keine Schuld an der ganzen Sache aber
spannend ist Richard das auch dass das
ich kannte das wirklich nicht wer muss
ja schon ein paar mal über Christentum
und so weiter unterhalten und ist auch
ein Thema für uns beide glaube ich in
unserem Leben immer gewesen mit mit
aller Liebe und aller Kritik die man
daran haben kann aber diese dieses Motiv
sozusagen den zum Guten um zu deuten ja
und die Schuld ausschließlich bei den
bösen Juden in dem Fall abzuladen damit
du nämlich sehr viel leichter ins
riesige römische Reich hinein
missionieren kann ja ist natürlich
eigentlich ein taktisch Sender zu
schnell genial Schachzug absolut ich die
also ich glaube eine Leistung wie die
die die die Paulus verbracht hat ja der
sicherlich irgendwie der kluge Kopf
dahinter ist ich habe glaube ich schon
meinen anderen Folge gesagt ich kann mir
Paulus immer nicht als Person vorstellen
ja manchmal denke ich paulus war der der
Name einer Gruppe oder irgendwas was
übrigens für die griechische Antike
nicht nicht seltsam wäre
ich auch oder so ja vielleicht später
muss auch nicht eine Person gewesen sein
also es ist berühmte mathematische
Lehrbuch des Euklid ist sicherlich nicht
von einem einzigen verfasst
interessanterweise es gab mal so eine
spannende
pädagogische Bewegung in der Mathematik
ich glaube so 60er Jahre da wurde die
Mathematik für die Schulen alle
preisiert ja vorher war die Geometrie
viel stärker und so weiter und die
nannten sich burbaki ja und das war
dasselbe in grün ein Herrn urbaki hat es
nie gegeben
und vielleicht auch bei Paulus also ich
kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass diese
Lebensleistung eine innere Organisation
zu schaffen das ganze Personal ja wer
ist für was zuständig wer kriegt welche
Ämter das alles zu erfinden die Regeln
für die Kirche festzulegen gleichzeitig
über ihn zu fahren Gemeinden zu gründen
Brief austauscht zu machen dass die auch
alle das richtige machen und nicht alle
anfangen irgendwas anderes zu glauben
also diese geniale organisationsleistung
ja also wohl gedanklich wie strukturell
also dieser Chef Manager und Chef
Ideologien eins ich kann mir kaum
vorstellen dass das eine Person war aber
ich weiß es natürlich nicht und ehrlich
gesagt weiß dass keiner
ich erfand so interessant wusste ich
vorher auch nicht eine der wirklich die
kuriosen Begleitumstände der Gründung
des Staates Israel im Jahr 48 ne ist
dass es zu der Zeit offensichtlich jede
Menge Petitionen gab in den vor allem
protestantische Christen den gerade erst
geschaffenen Obersten Gerichtshof in
Jerusalem dazu auffordern einen ganz
besonderen Prozess neu aufzurollen und
zwar den Prozess rund um die Anklage
gegen Jesus von Nazareth
habe ich nicht gewusst also dahinter
stand sozusagen die Idee ja kann man
natürlich darüber streiten dass dieser
Hohe Rat ja über den wir gerade
gesprochen haben der Jesus damals zum
Tode verurteilt und in dem vor den
Evangelien die Rede ist jetzt endlich
quasi einen rechts Nachfolger hatte ja
und das heißt man konnte sozusagen in
einem der umstrittensten Verfahren der
Geschichte jetzt mal den Revision gehen
das war die Idee obwohl noch nicht mal
ganz gesichert ist dass Jesus eine
historische Person ist nicht mal ganz
sicherlich dass es überhaupt diesen
Prozess gab ist ja interessant dass
dieser dieser
ruckzuck-prozess gegen Jesus dass der in
der jüdischen Tradition ja ganz anders
dargestellt wird nein er jüdischen
traditionelle
40 Tage gehabt genau also ein Prozess
über den wir ja nur Legenden und
Erzählungen haben ja Mythen den noch mal
aufzuräumen also ich hätte immer
interessant gefunden wenn der Prozess
gegen Galileo Galilei noch mal
aufgerollt worden weil das ist ja schon
eine ganz lange Forderung die man hat
der übrigens ist auch in sich hat und
über dem wir uns gerne mal unterhalten
können weil da vieles anders ist als man
das so aus der Schule kennt aber das
wird Jesus das soll ich weiß gar nicht
hat uns jemand das ernst genommen was
man das mal versucht also es gab
Petitionen dazu aber aus genannten
Gründen ja
ist das offensichtlich dann im Sand der
verlaufen aber ich fand es halt eben
jetzt mal interessant mit dir darüber zu
reden wann sich eigentlich ne wenn man
sich anschaut das ganze Personal um das
es geht Ausnahme Pontius Pilatus ist
jüdisch aber das Gefühl ist ein anderes
ja und das Gefühl auch von von von
Christen wenn du als als Kind so wie ich
auch wenn du christlich erzogen bist ist
in dieser Vorstellung ist Jesus kein
Jude na jesus ist Jesus der steht
sozusagen für sich Gottes Sohn hat der
hat ja keine keine Nationalität richte
keinen Pass und interessant ist diese
diese Trennung sozusagen von von
Judentum und Christen Eigentum das ist
ja das was da faktisch stattgefunden hat
die sich offensichtlich über
Jahrhunderte hingezogen hat und dazu
gehört dann irgendwann aber auch so eine
ja so wie soll man sagen so eine so eine
latente und dann auch glaube ich weniger
latente Abwertung des jüdischen ne was
dann zur Identität auch dieser noch sehr
jungen Kirche gehört und wenn man da mal
so genau reinschaut das ist eigentlich
bis heute nicht so wirklich überwunden
ich bin mir sicher dass du wo an der ein
oder anderen Stelle heute auch noch in
der Kirche wenn du sagst du sag mal
jesus war doch jetzt eigentlich ein Jude
oder nicht da würdest du glaube ich die
ein oder andere Augenbraue sehen die
sich sehr nach oben persönlich haben
Menschen kennengelernt die im Dritten
Reich
überzeugte Nazis waren
und
gleichzeitig sehr katholisch und bei
denen kam tatsächlich das Argument die
haben unseren Heiland ans Kreuz
geschlagen ja ich weiß das ist also das
kam auch diese Gespräche sind jetzt 20
Jahre alt das kommt damit einer völligen
Selbstverständlichkeit und ohne
irgendein Skrupel oder so wurde das
thematisiert übrigens gibt es noch eine
eine Nebengeschichte die ich interessant
finde und wenn ich in meinem Leben mal
richtig viel Zeit hätte und was
vielleicht nicht mehr vorkommt dann
würde ich das gerne noch mal versuchen
irgendwie weiter zu ergründen ob man da
irgendwie weiterkommen kann es gibt ja
noch eine spannende Spur zu Jesus
und diese spannende Spur ist du
erinnerst dich ja die Römer wollen ja
dann nicht so so gemein sein gegenüber
den Israelis also den Juden wenn Sie den
den Jesus ans Kreuz schlagen wollen sie
ja gleichzeitig dafür in den Macher was
freilassen richtig und Barbara was soll
ja so ein politischer Freiheitskämpfer
gewesen sein also der Mann der für die
Römer ja viel gefährlicher ist Jesus war
ja nur der Spinner der die die Stellagen
umgeschmissen hat im Tempel genau ja
also der war jetzt für die Römer nicht
so ein riesen Bedrohung das war Regung
öffentlichen ärgern ist es in seiner
sensiblen Zeit an einem sensiblen Ort
genau und da macht man kurzen
Prozesse richtig gefährlich das war ein
Aufwickler ein Aufrührer und so weiter
und das Interessante ist dass diese
Figur des Barbara was genau so schlecht
historisch belegtes wie Jesus
wenn man aber den Namen auseinander
nimmt Barabas dann heißt das Sohn des
Vaters ja und es gibt
Theorien die schon relativ früh
aufgetaucht ist sich zu sagen diesen
Barabas den hat es so sicher nicht
gegeben aber diesen Jesus hat es
vielleicht so auch nicht gegeben
vielleicht ist das ein und dieselbe
Person gewesen was dann die man dann
unter anderem tatsächlich gibt es daraus
die Tiere dass Jesus vielleicht gar
nicht ans Kreuz geschlagen wurde sondern
dass er dieser Barabas war und frei
gelassen wurde das also schon die
Kreuzigung eine Fiktion ist plus der
Fiktion dann vom leeren Grab noch da
drauf spannend oder das umgekehrt dieser
Bacher was ans Kreuz geschlagen worden
ist die man dann aber nicht gebrauchen
konnte weil er keine religiöse Figur war
und daraus dann die Jesus quasi aus dem
Haus destilliert hat als Sohn des
himmlischen Vaters interessant ist es
gibt einen ein schwedischen
Historiker der schon um die letzte
Jahrhundertwende
die Theorie aufgestellt hat das Barabas
und Jesus dieselbe Personen sind Yilmaz
Söderberg und es ist nicht so als ob man
das jetzt gleich als großes
Science-Fiction Weg tun man hat das so
ein bisschen romanhaft gestaltet aber
immer wenn ich mir das angucke denke ich
das könnte auch ein irgendwie ganz guter
Riecher gewesen sein was fügt sich
ziemlich gut zusammen ja er ist
interessant ich meine wenn man sich
diese also ich sag's mal so es gibt ja
wenn du auch im im heutigen modernen
Israel unterwegs bist es gibt da so
unfassbar viel nennen wir es positiv
religiöses Talent ich glaube das hat was
da auch mit dieser Landschaft zu tun ja
also Menschen Hirten die in diesem Kagen
nichts unterwegs sind bitte bitte Arm
die haben natürlich immer die
Vorstellung von einem besseren Leben
irgendwo weil das Leben in dieser als
irgendwie eine einzige Quälerei war und
ich glaube dass diese leeren Räume also
buchstäblich leeren Räume und dieser
gigantische Sternenhimmel da über die
als werde ich schon wieder romantisch
wie du merkst aber diese Nächte da
draußen in der Wüste die machen
natürlich was mit dir und ich glaube
schon dass diese Abwesenheit von von
anderen Dingen dann irgendwann dazu
führt dass du dir anfängst großartige
Geschichten auszudenken und die Bibel
ist eine Ansammlung von ganz großartigen
Geschichten also inwendige Vater Morgana
also tagsüber Flimmer das Licht ja und
du siehst Dinge die nicht da sind und
nachts leuchten die Sterne ja und du
siehst wieder Dinge die nicht da sind ja
sie ist Vater Morgana to go weißt du
einfach gemacht
ich habe das auch schon häufiger gesagt
ich bin ja für spirituelles durchaus
empfänglich
also
ich trenne das einfach in lauter
verschiedene Dinge ich finde hier sind
Sachen die gehören nicht zusammen also
das eine sind religiöse Geschichten
haben mich immer interessiert und
fasziniert na ich war in der
evangelischen Jungschar ich habe in der
katholischen Religion über das leere
Grab übrigens schriftlich Abitur gemacht
ich habe mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt
Theologie zu studieren ja ich könnte mir
eine Existenz als Pfarrer ziemlich gut
vorstellen aber ich hatte das Problem
dann als ich in der evangelischen Kirche
war habe ich dann irgendwie in
ziemlichen Groll gegen die evangelische
Kirche entwickelt und Priester wollte
ich nicht werden deswegen habe ich dann
keine Theologie studiert aber fasziniert
und interessiert hat mich das alles ja
es ist und der der die die
Daseinsberechtigung des spirituellen
schweißt sich einfach daraus dass unser
Wirbeltier Gehirn mit dem wir alle
ausgestattet sind ja
im Evolutionsprozess optimiert wurde für
die Funktion sich praktisch im Leben
zurechtzufinden früher in der Savanne
heute in Großstädten oder im
bauerndorfern oder wo auch immer wir
leben ja aber dass dieses Gehirn
natürlich nicht optimiert wurde um große
und unendliche Wahrheiten zu erkennen
sondern immer wenn es um die ganz großen
Dinge geht stoßt stößt dieses Gehirn an
Grenzen und dann merkt es auch dass es
nichts kapiert ja also
schon wunderbar sein berühmten
antiomieren ja also sozusagen
Widersprüchen des Denkens aufgezeichnet
zum Beispiel können wir uns wir haben
über Willensfreiheit gesprochen ja wir
können uns Willens Freiheit nicht
vorstellen aber wird das ist keine
Willensfreiheit gibt können wir uns
eigentlich auch nicht vorstellen ja wenn
man es wirklich mal ernst nimmt ja klar
noch viel dramatischer ist es mit
Unendlichkeit
wir können uns Unendlichkeit nicht
vorstellen aber auf der einen Seite was
ist das Universum wo ist es unendlich
oder ist es unendlich ja wir können uns
ein endliches Universum nicht vorstellen
was ist denn hinter dem Endlichen
Universum ja aber Unendlichkeit können
wir uns auch nicht vorstellen wir können
uns keinen Anfang der Zeit vorstellen
also müsst ihr die Zeit unendlich sein
aber unendliche Zeit wie gesagt können
wir uns nicht vorstellen richtig das
heißt also wir merken plötzlich unser
Gehirn ist in der Lage Fragen zu stellen
die größer sind als es selbst die ist
nicht in der Lage ist zu beantworten das
heißt wir sind wir sind was Größen waren
angeht besonders begabt wir sind begabt
in den größten waren der Fragen ja und
alle Antworten die wir darauf geben und
die waren auch manchmal mit
holzhackerischer Sicherheit gibt wie in
den Religionen ja wissen wie immer sind
mit Sicherheit falsch ja weil es einfach
zu groß für unser Gehirn ist das
bedeutet aber zugleich das ist natürlich
unglaublich viel Dinge in der Welt geben
kann die real sind die wir aber nicht
Streifen die wir nicht erfassen können
die aber irgendwie da sind die wir mit
unserer Vorstellung von Kausalität also
Ursache und Wirkung nicht erklären
können die wir nicht auf Materielles
oder auf Gesetze zurückführen können und
die trotzdem wirken und wenn wir das
einmal begriffen haben dass das
tatsächlich so ist und dass wir uns da
nur so in unserer Menschenwelt
eingerichtet haben wenn wir versuchen
die Natur zu verstehen dann ist man
prinzipiell vorsichtig mit
materialistischen Erklärungen sondern
dann sagt man sich okay das ist nur das
was wir jetzt gut erklären können aber
es gibt natürlich auch ganz viel was
wenn ich erklären können wir sind so
klein und wenn man dann so unter dem
Sternenhimmel ja dieses ästhetische
Gefühl seiner Kleinheit empfinden ja
dann kapiert man plötzlich das ist gar
nicht so schlimm ist dass man so klein
ist sondern dann denkt man wie schön ist
das dass ich so ein kleines Stück
Sternenstaub in diesem ganzen und dann
erfahren schon etwas davon von dieser
Größe die uns umgibt die wenn ich
erfassen können und das ist der Ursprung
meines Erachtens aller Spiritualität
nicht der Religion die Religion hatte
viele andere Funktionen Rechtsprechung
Gesellschaft Regeln und so weiter aber
von Spiritualität und Spiritualität kann
man nicht materialistisch aus dem
Menschen rauskürzen das glaube ich auch
jetzt wirst du poetisch Richard nee
einfach nur so das Ergebnis von 50
Jahren nachdenken
der Mensch braucht das Übernatürliche
genauso wie den kleinen Planeten den er
bewohnt ja das glaube ich auch ich
glaube es ist wirklich ja und das
Interessante ist dass ich also wie tief
das in uns drin steckt ne und deswegen
ist auch dieses Thema Ostern und das
Wunder von Ostern und das Wunder der
Wiederauferstehung und so weiter
das ist ja das ist ja etwas dem sich
selbst Kleinkinder in Wahrheit nicht
entziehen können ne
es ist es ist faszinierend das zu sehen
wenn du mit wenn kleine Kinder diesen
diesen Sternenhimmel sehen ja dann dann
hast du genau das dann merkst Du
plötzlich welches spirituelle talenti
haben es ist unglaublich gut und ich
weiß ich habe ich hatte diesbezüglich
man sehr interessantes Gespräch
ich habe das auch in diesem kleinen Buch
beschrieben dass ich mit Manfred Lütz
Jungs veröffentlicht habe über über
Papst Benedikt
dieses Buch ist entstanden gar nicht
wichtig und man muss das auch nicht
lesen und so weiter aber es war uns
irgendwie wichtig noch einmal fest zu
halten was dieser Mann in diesem letzten
Gespräch dass wir mit ihm hatten was der
zu sagen hat hatte und da taucht ein
Gedanke zum Beispiel der der mich bis
heute wahnsinnig fasziniert darin auf
ich habe ihn mal gefragt ob er mir sagen
könne verbindlich ja als Chef der
Glaubensgruppe gehört zum wieder Liebe
Gottes aussieht ob er jetzt ein Bart hat
oder nicht hatte so gelacht und guckte
mich dann an und er hat dann eine
wunderschöne Antwort und da sagte mit
dem Bart hat oder nicht kann ich ihn
natürlich nicht sagen aber ich kann
Ihnen sagen wenn sie mit offenen Augen
durchs Leben gehen dann werden sie immer
wieder Menschen treffen bei denen ab und
zu etwas Göttliches durchschimmert und
das fand ich wahnsinnig schön und
deswegen gefragt welche Menschen das bei
ihnen gewesen sind bei ihm nicht aber
ich ich möglicherweise habe ich das auch
aber ich erinnere mich nicht mehr an die
Antwort aber was ich zum Beispiel sagen
kann ist und das wirst du auch
bestätigen so in diesem ganz
ungezwungenen ganz aufrichtigungen
ehrlichen Gespräch zum Beispiel mit
Kindern da kannst du das Erleben genau
das
sagenhaftigkeit ja man kann das
natürlich auch Wichtigkeit einerseits
sagen Kinder sind wahnsinnig begabt zu
glauben weil sie keine Alternative dazu
haben richtig sie müssen ja die Dinge
glauben sie lernen ja das was ihre
Eltern sagen zu glauben weil sie es
nicht wissen können und was ist nicht
überprüfen können wichtig
aber die Fähigkeit zu glauben und auch
mehr zu glauben als nur das was man hört
sondern auch dann Dinge zu glauben die
man sich selbst zusammengereimt hat oder
was Kinder ja in bestimmten Alter häufig
machen sich imaginäre Personen
vorzustellen mit denen sich unterhalten
mein Sohn hat das auch mal gemacht und
es kommt häufiger bei Kindern genau also
diese diese enorme Fantasie begabtheit
beim Spielen Kinder wissen ja dass sie
spielen wenn sie spielen aber sie können
gleichzeitig unendlich darin versinken
richtig das sind ja wahrscheinlich ist
das ja alles ein ein wirklich tiefes
Erbe das nicht nur ein pädagogischen
Sinn hat ja sondern dass das hat etwas
vom ursprünglichen Bezug des Menschen
gegenüber der Natur der ja sehr
weitgehend einen Glaubens und
erfahrungsbezug war und keinen Bezug der
sich auf abstraktes Wissen aufgebaut hat
wir wissen heute ganz ganz ganz ganz
viele Dinge die wir nie überprüfen wo
wir aber immer davon ausgehen dass die
Stimmen ja dass die Erde ganz alt ist
und sowas heißt ja da sagen sie
Wissenschaften ja das ist so vor zwei
Milliarden Jahren und so das ist ich
glaube das ja auch alles aber ich kann
das nicht überprüfen das heißt der ganze
Hintergrund meines Wissens besteht aus
Glauben darin dass die Quellen
vertraulich sind
ist richtig und auch unser Wissen ist ja
eine Form des Glaubens
es ist wahr wobei ich habe Ricky javeys
neulich gehört würde ich total
interessant der irgendwo in der
amerikanischen Late Night Show wars ich
glaube es war sogar die vollbär mit dem
man darüber gesprochen hat und die
unterhielten sich über die Frage
Wissenschaft versus Religion und und
Jerry sagte weißt du es ist ganz einfach
wenn wir diese ganzen heiligen Bücher
die Bibel und alles wenn wir die jetzt
einer ernsthaften Überprüfung
unterziehen würden dann würde das Kasse
Gegenteil dessen rauskommen was da drin
steht ja aber wenn wir wissenschaftliche
Bücher einer ernsthaften Überprüfung
unterziehen dann würde an den exakt
gleichen Stellen ziemlich genau wieder
das gleiche rauskommen was die
grundsätzlichen Formeln und und und und
Thesen oder und und ja Fakten alter das
ist sicher also der große Unterschied
die hat science ist ja wie die
Naturwissenschaften die beschäftigen
sich mit den softproblems also bei der
Frage über wie viel Grad kocht Wasser
aber
die Philosophie ja die beschäftigen sich
mit den hardpromens ja warum gibt es die
Welt ja oder warum passen man und Frauen
nicht zusammen und so weiter und auf
diese Fragen gibt es keine endgültigen
definitiven messbaren und überprüfbaren
Antworten und deswegen sind die
Naturwissenschaften so erfolgreich und
wirkt die Philosophie auf den ersten
Blick so erfolglos aber es liegt einfach
daran dass ihre Probleme hundertmal
schwieriger sind
da kommst du jetzt noch mal schön aus
der Nummer raus das finde ich sehr gut
Richard aber du hast natürlich Recht und
weißt du noch ein ganz schneller Gedanke
zum Schluss ich habe ja immer wieder mit
Menschen zu tun die unendlich viel
schlauer sind als ich selbst und das
empfinde ich als eines der Privilegien
dieser Arbeit unter anderem im Gespräch
mit dir
wenn du mit diesen Leuten sprichst und
dazu gehört er eben auch Papst Benedikt
ja der glaube ich dieses Papst Thomas
große lastempfunden hat das hat dem
nicht wirklich Spaß gemacht
aber darüber nachzudenken
genau ich glaube Papst zu sein ist
irgendwie die Hölle auf Erden aber die
die anderen die großen Fragen sich mit
denen zu beschäftigen es war ein
unendlich kluger Mensch und gleichzeitig
hat mich so fasziniert und das
Beschreiben eben auch in diesem kleinen
Büchlein wie der auf der anderen Seite
ganz kindlich im besten Sinne glauben
konnte auf die Frage was er sich
vorstellt nach seinem Tod sagte er ich
freue mich dann meine Mutter
wiederzusehen und mein Vater
wiederzusehen und mich hat das
wahnsinnig berührt weil ich dachte wie
schön ist es wenn jemand das so ganz
naiv und ganz ernsthaft wirklich glaubt
und auf der anderen Seite diese große
Ehrlichkeit das hat mich damals wirklich
gepackt und das war auch der Moment wo
ich dachte das muss man mal aufschreiben
damit die Leute das auch lesen können
dies interessiert ich frage den ob einer
wie er Angst vor den Tod hat und er
sagte ganz ehrlich ja ich habe große
Angst davor weil ich nicht weiß wie
dieses sterben ablaufen wird und ich
fand das so berührend deswegen weil ich
genau weiß wenn ich mit meinem Dorf
Pfarrer damals darüber gesprochen hätte
der hätte mir irgendwas erzählt von das
ist der Übergang in ein anderes Leben
eine andere Existenz eine höhere Form
des Seins und so weiter hätte da
irgendwas religiös philosophisch
verbremtes mir von Latz geknallt aber
wäre nicht ehrlich gewesen aber dieser
große Mann war in dem Moment ganz klein
und ganz ehrlich
Kinder glauben denn dahinter ist ja ist
ja die die Vorstellung seine Eltern
wiederzusehen
leibliche Auferstehung richtig und nicht
geistige auferstich genau ja was also
schon wirklich speziell ist und jetzt
könnte man unendlich fortfahren es gibt
nämlich eine lange Diskussion über die
Frage der beruflichen Auferstehung wie
sieht man dann aus ja da wurde
tatsächlich über die Jahrhunderte so
lange darüber diskutiert bis die Kirche
das mit der leiblichen Auferstehung
irgendwann so Stück für Stück immer
weiter reduziert hat und sich mehr und
mehr an die griechische Vorstellung
angelehnt hat der geistigen Auferstehung
die dieses Problem ja nicht hat richtig
weil die Seele oder der Spirit oder der
Logos oder was auch immer der hat ja
keine keine körperliche Gestalt also ich
weiß ich erinnere mich aus den
Diskussionen wenn man sich da mit
theologischen Büchern beschäftigt hat
das ist also einerseits die Vorstellung
gab dass alle aussehen wie sie außer mit
30 in dem Alter als Jesus starb super
was natürlich den Nachteil hat wenn man
mit 30 erblindet war z.B oder sowas ja
oder ganz schwere Krankheiten hatte sind
die dann weg
oder bleibt man blind im Himmel und die
andere Vorstellung war das aus einer
einzelnen Körperzelle Zelle kannte man
noch nicht aber aus einem mikroteil des
Körpers quasi ein idealer Körper seiner
selbst hergestellt wurde ich glaube
tinetopsychismus oder so ähnlich nannte
sich das ja also so eine gentechnische
Fantasie oder reproduktionsmedizinische
Fantasien quasi zellformierung oder
wegen der Petrischale da kriegt der
Begriff petri-schale
ganz andere Bedeutung es war super wir
werden quasi in der Petrischale wieder
neu zusammengemixt wenn wir in die Hand
bekommen und jetzt Richard das aktuell
im Anlass noch mal übersetzen ins 21
Jahrhundert wenn man dann leiblich auch
versteht ist das Botox dann raus oder
noch drin
was man nicht du siehst es gibt noch
ziemlich viele hard Problems die nicht
gelöst sind und ich freue mich drauf wir
sollten wir sollten mal eine Folge
machen Richard vielleicht in den
nächsten Wochen über die interessante
wirklich spannende Frage die daran ja
eigentlich anschließt ich meine über
Jahrtausende hinweg haben Menschen
versucht irgendwie zu überleben und
Tagen geben wir haben gegen Hunger Krieg
und und Krankheit gekämpft gegen Seuchen
und so weiter aber plötzlich jetzt im
dritten Jahrtausend stehen in einem
Punkt wo wir möglicherweise kurz davor
sind den Tod und Geschehen zu machen ja
harari nennt das die letzten Tage des
Todes und und das und das ist ein
wahnsinnig spannendes Thema was
resultiert daraus und ist das überhaupt
der strebenswert was kann man leben
genau was kann man aus Kulturen lernen
ja durch die Art und Weise wie sie mit
dem Tod umgehen und die andere Frage ist
eine ganz großartige Frage wie
erstrebenswert ist eigentlich das ewige
Leben darüber sollten wir uns noch mal
in Ruhe unterhalten richtig ich ich lege
mich fest ich möchte jetzt nicht haben
in diesem Sinne Richard frohe Ostern
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]